on commence tout de suite avec nathalie
loiseau elle a donc figurait sur la une
liste qui regroupe et la droite et
l'extrême droite lorsqu'elle était
étudiante à sciences po une liste bâtie
sur les cendres du gud selon mediapart
qui a sorti l'information
une erreur a plaidé nathalie l'oiseau à
la mi journée
mais quand même peut-être un petit
caillou dans la chaussure de la tête de
liste en marche
on en parle tout de suite mais d'abord
on écoute nathalie oiseaux oui il ya 35
ans j'ai commis une erreur
j'ai accepté par amitié de figurer sur
une liste où il y avait des gens de
droite des gaullistes mais il y avait
aussi des gens d'extrême droite
et ça je ne le savais pas j'aurais dû le
vérifier je le regrette
c'est une erreur 10 à 35 ans déjà on
s'arrête un tout petit peu sur la forme
donc à commun une communication via
twitter à mi-journée la polémique était
déjà engagée je les trouve alors la
forme c'est toujours difficile de parler
face caméra moi je trouve ça très
difficile donc je vais pas l'attaquer
sur la forme et sur le fond je trouve
que les deux arguments qu'elle a
utilisée elle a d'abord utilisé
l'argument du féminisme en disant il
fallait ouvrir aux femmes donc on m'a
demandé mais c'est absolument
antiféministe son argument du féminisme
parce que si c'est juste ouvrir aux
femmes c'est pas un bien en soi si c'est
les femmes sont à être là pour être là
c'est tout sauf ministre donc c'est
absolument pas un homme aimant il ya 34
ans mais il ya 30 15 ans va si c'est
juste être là pour être là pour ouvrir
femmes quelles que soient les actions
qu'on lui demande de mener c'est
vraiment ça ne sera pas pour voilà c'est
ça il ya 50 ans non plus à s'entendre
non plus dans 200 ans non plus c'est pas
du tout un argument qui tient donc le
féminisme a bon dos et deuxièmement
l'argument l'ignorance je ne savais pas
donc soit les superficielle soit elle
est insouciant pour une femme qui se
consacrent un carrière politique c'est
un peu ennuyeux je pense que le bon
argument mois aurait été de jouer sur le
changement c'est à dire quinze vingt ans
on peut très bien comprendre qu'on est
des extraits mais on a besoin d'exister
de ceux de se démarquer etc
mais elle n'a pas utilisé cet argument
là parce qu'elle a je pense amalgames et
le fait de changer et le fait d'être
incohérent et seraient des signes
d'incohérences mais pas du tout le
changement peut être aussi un signe de
maturité et d'intelligence parfois alors
on continue d'en parler mais comme julia
un petit peu empiéter sur l'argumentaire
on va écouter alors celle de ian brossât
tête de liste du parti communiste vous
allez voir il a quelques arguments qui
sont pas si éloignées quand on voit
toute la communication en fait par la
république en marche qui se présente
comme seul rempart face à l'extrême
droite
c'est sûr que tout cela fait un peu
désordre et puis par ailleurs les
explications qu'elle avance pour
justifier le fait d'avoir été présente
sur sept listes sont peu convaincantes
quand elle dit je n'ai pas perçu la
couleur politique de cette liste alors
même qu'elle était en quatrième année de
sciences po et qu'elle prépare l ena
c'est vrai que ça laisse pantois c'est
un peu là richard virenque de la
politique elle était candidate à l'insu
de son plein gré et erwan redon
quand on fouille dans le patient on
trouve toujours finalement je veux tous
tendance à considérer que ce qu'elle a
fait il ya 35 ans on peut effectivement
qu'on va imaginer que cela n'influence
pas sa conception de la vie publique de
la politique aujourd'hui je pense que en
cherchant dans la ville dans le passé 35
ans en arrière de tous les hommes
politiques on peut trouver des positions
extrêmes des positions qui sont
potentiellement contradictoire avec
celle qu'ils ont aujourd'hui donc je
trouve qu'il ya une polémique et
peut-être pas de sens par contre ce qui
est plus surprenant de mon point de vue
c'est effectivement la réaction date et
l'oiseau qui par ses maladresses fin
donne du moulin donne de l'eau au moulin
de la polémique qui à la retraite a fait
si loin et un dans 10 ans était à 35 ans
tout le monde fait des erreurs de
jeunesse
j'ai du mal à croire que quand on est à
sciences po fin je suis passé par
sciences po il ya moins longtemps
être de droite à sciences po s'engager
sur une liste de droite c'est pas super
sympa je sais pas c'est pal l'accueil
surtout dans le disque est visiblement
où il y avait des manques du gud si j'ai
bien compris quand même c'est pas
complètement anodin c'est vrai que c'est
son délice qui chaque année ont du mal à
peut-être à trouver des candidats et
c'est plus c'est plus compliqué c'est à
les défendre dans les amphithéâtres en
étant un candidat du but qu'en étant un
candidat de gauche dans dans cet
établissement mais donc raison de plus
pour considérer qu'elle devait être au
courant de ce qu'elle faisait mais à la
limite ce qui même si elle sait ne s'en
souvient plus c'est c'était il ya 35 ans
peut lui pardonner je trouve que la
réaction l'argumentation en donne de
l'eau au moulin de la polémique et laura
lui étant assez rapidement mauvaise
défense de nathalie oiseaux oui ça s'est
su après mauvaise défense aux stands qui
en a eu trois ou quatre successives
parce qu'elle a commencé par dire
c'était faux sauf que malheureusement ce
n'était pas faux c'est vrai ensuite elle
a dit qu'elle avait oublié
ensuite elle a dit qu'elle n'avait pas
vu que c'était l'extrême droite
et après ils disent c'est une erreur une
connerie ça alors ça c'est évidemment
catastrophique pas voilà ça c'est assez
grave parce que c'est grave sur elle
aujourd'hui pas sur elle il ya 35 ans
donc
par ailleurs je trouve que on est allé
un peu vite en besoin qui aurait mérité
d'enquêté moi je vais essayer de savoir
cet après midi qu est-ce qui et comment
cette liste présentait vous avez raison
liste apolitique on sent bien que c'est
ni de droite mais c'est possible aussi
que la liste était très masqué dans son
côté des stands quand les qui fabrique
des listes à sciences po et qu'ils
essayent de racoler quelqu'un il viendra
pas venir sur ma liste ne laissa pas
c'est le pluralisme install va pas dire
attention j'ai des gens d'extrême droite
que c'est un copain il me demande oui
donc il y avait beaucoup de façons de
s'en sortir mais d'une certaine manière
lcl c'est comment dire elle se doit
elle-même ce qui fait qu'à l'arrivée ou
si j'essaie de dire les soirs avec des
termes pas trop des champs où elle a
manqué d'intelligence où elle a un
rapport curieux la vérité mes chansons
était idiote tout mensonge alexis il
faut aussi se remettre pas il faut
penser ce que c'était que la droite il
ya 35 ans et le l'extrême droite 35 ans
et c'est à cette époque là il ya 35 ans
loiseau moi j'étais à droite c'est sûr
mais je n'osais pas du tout politique
des trucs mais n'empêche que l'oiseau
elle vient de la droite on le sait elle
était plutôt elle était juriste elle
vient plutôt de l'environnement et
repères mais qu'ils aient eu à cette
époque là plein de passerelle entre le
but de leur père comme de cinq ou dix
ans plus tôt il avait plein entre
occident et les républicains dépensent
cardiaque et tout le monde c'est pas bon
et il y avait une espèce de notamment
dans les milieux étudiants espèce de
porosité entre les études les jeunes rpr
et des jeunes du gud les jeunes occident
avant maintenant longues etc
les jeunes républicains indépendants qui
étaient des jeunes giscardiens enfin bon
tout ça donc à mon avis elle a
absolument tort effectivement d'abord
veut dire que c'est pas vrai puis de
battre sa coupe
le seul truc qu'elle affecte mon avis
qui était pas mal c'est de taper plenel
en 10 ans a baissé de monsieur plenel
qui vient de donner des leçons
mediapart a évidemment vous n'aimez pas
plenel donc salle s'est vidée alors les
seniors mais elle
si on fait ça il faut faire sans se
tromper plenel n'a jamais été ma liste
il a prêté de malice elle n'a jamais été
mon utilité trotskiste oui si vous tapez
quelqu'un moi si je tabriz et le précise
la vie paloise il avait valu traoré diop
juive non dit mariniste ailleurs oui
mais ça n'empêche qu'elle y avait deux
coups de quoi dire quand même sur plein
air sur tariq ramadan sur plein de
sujets etc
le l'islamo gauchisme de plenel il a
mené il y avait suffisamment de choses à
faire sur plenel pour pour et sur le
trotskisme de plenel par ailleurs pour
pour nourrir une une petite attaque donc
elle a eu tort alors maintenant c'est
vrai que ça va l'embêté pas ce que ça va
lui coller à la côte à la pause écoute
incapacitant consent depuis le début de
cette campagne européenne que macro on
était sur un logiciel au début qui
étaient les méchants nationaliste les
progressistes contre les peuples et c
il a plutôt abandonné ça et on a vu
qu'il a loi voté davantage là dessus ce
qui est sûr c'est que maintenant il
pourra pas faire tous les quatre matins
les horribles nationalistes et les
européenne quand même qui paie c'est
inhabituel c'est que je pense que du
fait d'une part de l'absence des grands
grands poids lourds de la politique à la
tête des listes et d'autre part du fait
que les positions ont les uns les autres
sont quand même très très proche et il
sait pas il pas radicalement différent
du coup la tête de liste ça compte plus
qu on aurait pu croire et donc ceux qui
sont des bonnes campagnes qui émerge
comme claire authentique compréhensible
vont l'emporter en tout cas vont gagner
des points sur ce qui patauge dans la
semoule émergent comme claire
compréhensible
bon je dirais le candidat tête de liste
communiste le candidat tête de liste
républicain ces deux là c'est flagrant
me semble-t-il
non bellamy au début qu'on avait la
bible à hébron ça effectivement il était
là il est assez drôle il est très bon et
on ne connaissait pas bellamy au début
quand il a accroché sur les histoires
d'hiver etc
il dit c'est à titre personnel mais dit
pas je n'ai pas dit je regrette et j'ai
eu tort il dit oui c'est comme ça et
mais c'est pas le sujet elle avait qu'à
lire ne souhaite pas le sujet de savoir
ce que j'ai fait il ya 35 ans on s'en
fiche un peu pour la campagne européenne
alors on va revoir le l'entrée en
campagne de nathalie l'oiseau vous
souvenez c'était lors de cette émission
sur france 2 où elle avait eu aussi un
rapport à la vérité le mot est peut-être
un peu fort mais en tout cas une entrée
en campagne un peu surprenante à la
sincérité mercier l'ex on l'écouté
madame le pen je voudrais vous dire
bravo bravo parce que vous avez réussi à
me faire changer d'avis je suis entré
sur ce plateau et je voulais dit vous ai
dit que ce n'était pas candidate pour
conduire la liste de la majorité
moi j'ai envie d'une robe du partage et
pas d'une europe de la division vous
avez changé de ce soir c'est vrai je
suis prêt à être candidate vous fait
effectivement le lien entre les deux
séquences on peut faire un parallèle
entre eux sont ces explications un peu
alambiqué d'aujourd'hui je peux toujours
remonté je cherchais des explications
psychologiques mais là c'est
manifestement elle veut faire un coup
elle veut marquer et c'est avec des
recettes d'il ya 14 mille ans et qu'elle
met mal en oeuvre donc ça marche pas le
côté oh là là là j'ai changé d'avis
c'est ridicule ça c'est de l'amateurisme
c'est que julia de funès n'était pas ce
conseiller
parce que julie a voulu oric et
conseillez quoi je n'aurais rien
conseiller je n'ai pas cette prétention
là mais c'est vrai que c'est confus dans
la forme le fait de ces très préparée
elle joue la spontanéité et dans le cas
inverse c'est salir spontanée mais c'est
très confus donc bon il ya un problème
de clarté c'est vrai mais ce qu'on
remarque et puis notre discussion le
prouvent ses consoeurs on se en dix ans
qui est bon maintenant dans les têtes de
listes pour les européennes on se ne
s'attache qu'à la forme en dix ans il y
en a qui sont claires qui s'exprime bien
qu'ils sont drôles et le programme
européen on n'en parle pas du tout donc
on va en parler d'âge est sûr de voir
par lui oui j'ai ce portage de l'oiseau
d'ailleurs c'est faux quand elle n'a
toujours pas pu le présenter son
programme passe comme à quoi au juste
quelques réactions d'abord de nos
internautes à ce sujet alors d'abord la
question que vous posez tous convaincus
par les explications nathalie loiseau
vous avez une idée de la réponse olivier
77% de nom chaton nous dit une erreur de
jeunesse pourquoi pas mais pourquoi
mentir et vouloir cacher les choses r34
ce qui est important c'est ce qu'elle
représente maintenant et jeep nous dit
chirac a bien distribué l'humanité
babineau elle avait 20 ans un âge de
raison elle doit assumer c'est la
politique enfin nicole elle n'est pas
obligée de mentir et se renier ce n'est
pas honteux d'être de droite
alors effectivement à roanne on l'abordé
la campagne avec très courte
c'est dans un mois les élections c'est
sans cesse repoussée avec les événements
qu'on connaît une campagne trop courtes
jeu alors je serai olivier duhamel qui a
plus d'expérience que moi dans l'analyse
des campagnes mais il est vrai que si on
ne trompe pas les élections européennes
intérêts allemands - les électeurs
fratel d'une participation envisagée à
son tour de 45% donc c'est relativement
faible je connais tu mens je ne sais pas
compte tenu des candidats et des
programmes si six mois de campagne
aurait changé fondamentalement l'intérêt
des français au
à la campagne tels que lui je pense
qu'il ya jeu quand j'explique mais mais
mais grille de lecture libéral à la
politique je pense que pour qui et de la
demande il fait d'avoir qui est de
l'offre est qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il
offre qui pourrait créer l'enthousiasmé
elle est relativement absente qu'il ya
des offres qui crée une adhésion autre
extrême parce qu'ils ont un discours
relativement facile c'est facile de
dénoncer et donc les gens qui ont envie
de dénoncer envie de se retrouver dans
qu'ils ont exprimées soit d'adhésion
alors des secours soit de malaise
s'il retrouve que le discours pro
européen a aujourd'hui est aujourd'hui
assez peu audible donc je ne suis pas
que je suis pas convaincu que des mois
de campagne avec ce même discours
or fondamentalement changer les choses
il est évident que s'il y a que quinze
jours c'est probablement moi ou bien
moins bien que trois mois mais mais je
suis je reste sceptique
alexis pour la macro et fait tout pour
que la campagne soit la plus courte
possible
je sais pas si fait sans doute s'il doit
se dire que c'est toujours ça de gagné
et que vu sa candidate c'est peut-être
pas eu une inutile de faire campagne
façon interminable après la sphère des
gilet jaune c'est pas lui qui décide et
la certitude ralenti du grand débat
notre dame encore moins bon les
événements sont ce qu'ils sont et c'est
ce qui va ce qui aura pas eu de campagne
puisque toute façon ça va pas commencer
à vendre y avoir le week-end de doké
look and pas que voir le 1er mai donc
tout ça il restera au fond quinze jours
de campagne
c'est vrai que ça n'a jamais intéressé
grand monde bon malgré tout c'est pas
satisfaisant de se dire c'est comme ça
intéresse pas on va pas faire campagne
on pourrait se dire que en petit en
campagne ça pourrait intéresser les gens
ce qui est vrai et là je joue un rôle
mais on sait que ce qui était très
européen le sont un peu moins ce qui
était très anti le sont un peu moi je
rappelle que y compris le front national
de règlements de plus la sortie de
l'europe et plus la sortie de l'euro
donc tout ça se regroupent au milieu sur
des sujets ctions très technique pas
facile et si en plus on fait pas
campagne
à l'arrivée je serais bien étonné qu'on
et 45% de participation mais s'offre à
moi alors on va en parler olivier mais
dans le thème suivant mais finalement
les enjeux nationaux comme souvent
supplanté les enjeux internes même plus
que les enjeux nationaux ou même les
incarnations nationale parce que alexis
va un petit peu vite en besogne
il est vrai qu'il est assez jeune et que
je suis fort vieux mais quand il dit que
ça n'a jamais intéressé personne non au
début ça intéressait les élections c'est
une lente chute la participation mais
les premières élections européennes et
les seconds les troisièmes intéressait
beaucoup mais la première élection
européenne quels étaient les têtes de
lit c'était mitterrand d'un côté chirac
de l'autre en 9 79 ans 84 c'était jospin
simone veil en 89 c'était fabuleux
giscard en 94 7 et rocard baudis et
enfin en 99 c'était hollande
sarko pasqua et après ça s'arrête donc
quand vous aviez des élections dont les
têtes de listes étaient des
personnalités politique
extraordinairement importante
incarnez connu ça et des
considérablement la participation quand
ce sont des gens inconnus
ça aide - deuxièmement quand les
positions étaient très tranchées chirac
le parti de l'étranger
simone veil nous on a besoin de la
construction de l'ordre ça l'aide à
participer quand les républicains est en
marche ont le même programme où la
france un sourire les écolos ont
quasiment le même programme
c'est très difficile de de vouloir y
participer alors ajouter à tout ça
ajoutez à tout cela le déclin de la
participation en général la défiance à
l'égard du politique en général vous
avez les deux facteurs il ya des raisons
européenne d'une chute de la
participation il ya des raisons de
général d'une chute de l'apartheid
en fait je pense la complexité des
institutions européennes ce qui a les
thématiques qui sont pas simples et les
institutions c'est pas très bien quoi
sert ce parlement quelles sont ses
pouvoirs à quoi vont servir donc sinon
c'est pas avec ça parce qu'on voter pour
lui quand il avait pas de plus pour lui
que ça vaut tous les gens croyaient soit
près de 12 pour être contre mais c'était
un braquage
maintenant l'europe ça devient un
imbroglio pas possible on y comprend
plus rien le projet alors on va parler
effectivement de politique française
avec cette intervention des manuels
macron alors on le sait c'est une
conférence de presse ce jeudi par
journalistes interposés
un exercice nouveau pour le président à
un public puisque jusqu'à présent ils
avaient refusé de s'y prêter
les annonces elles elles sont largement
éventé
coût emmanuel macron pourra-t-il
surprendre c'est la question que l'on
vous pose et on en parle tout de suite
et roanne le mans vous poseriez quelle
question
si jeudi la conférence de presse
heureusement je ne serai pas mais la
question que lui pose